hey everybody is Jessie sorry
started a little bit late I had I guess
I'm only three minutes late not as bad
as I thought I had a problem with
something I had made months ago and now
basically we were using this plugin with
Salesforce to let people register for
events to come visit campus and the
default styles were just really really
outdated even like to look at the code
they were using versions of like
JavaScript plugins that were like 10
years old it was really bad so I went in
and did the best I could in customizing
it and bringing it up to like our brand
standards so it turns out that on May
15th all of everything I had done wasn't
working anymore and it reverted back to
the default the only reason I know that
is because part of what I did was at
Google Analytics code so that's the
point when the analytics stop coming in
for those pages and I had never gone on
because they had been working well for
at that point weeks at least weeks and
tested it everything was fine so it
didn't realize until today that it
wasn't working so I was trying to figure
that out
at the point when I realized that I
don't know what's going on then I I
needed to send an email and get it
forward on to the company we have an odd
set up right now so we we're using a
Salesforce product to take applications
for people who want to go to our
University and for other things but
we're using a product that's being
resold by another company and they're
all all they are doing is just taking
this Salesforce plugin so that basically
there's like two other companies between
us and Salesforce
so I can't go directly to Salesforce for
support and I can't go to the company
that made the plug-in we have to first
go to this company that's reselling the
plug-in so it's really complicated and I
have no direct contact with any any
people that can that can help me out so
I have to go to my IT department first
then they go to one of the companies and
that company will problem maybe have to
go to the company that made the plug-in
it's just a big mess so anyway that's
that's why I was delayed so again I
apologize so let me I want to check and
see if we how many people we have in
here now so you can get started ok cool
so we have a decent number around 50
people so so let's get started I let me
start out I haven't given my normal
starting thing so I know there have been
a lot of new people from the live chat
so just to let everyone know this this
stream is just me doing my everyday work
I am employed full-time as a front-end
developer so this is me doing my work so
it's not exactly a tutorial although
hopefully you learn how to do some
things when you watch this and it is
very much interactive so I take advice
from you all and a live chat and also a
pool request for the projects of which
I've had a lot recently which is awesome
thank you I do make a lot of mistakes
and that's intended because I really
want you all to see what it's really
like for me to do this so I don't
rehearse any of it beforehand and I just
want to give you a glimpse into what
it's like for me to do front-end
development I don't know if I'm like the
average developer or not I'm not really
sure how well my day relates to other
developers but at least it might give
you an idea of what one developer does
alright so having having said all that
let me fill you in on what's been done
since yesterday
and what we're gonna do today so
basically let me get this was for a
little es6 exercise i was doing so i can
get rid of that these are some resources
I was reading over the Kevin sent
yesterday in the live stream or the live
chat let me show you okay so we've added
we've added some things for testing in
order to test the upload thing so no one
will ever see this unless you're
submitting pull requests or anything but
it's just gonna allow us to do testing
on the file upload input that we have
and what else has happened a lot of
refactoring has gone on and all this
stuff was from pull requests so I had
some pull requests from Patrick and some
from Kevin and basically just
refactoring the service request page so
you can see there's a big difference so
I'm not gonna go over at all for two
reasons one it'll take up a lot of time
because so much has changed and also the
second reason is I know that it works
because I tested it but I'm still trying
to figure it out myself so I don't want
to try to stumble through explaining
what's going on here when I wouldn't be
able to do a good job of explaining
everything but maybe if I broke it down
into small pieces but but for right now
basically what it does is you can see
the labels for the input elements are
now here okay so everything's in
in-state now really so the labels are
here for all our multi-line fields so
really I mean you this is somewhat
self-explanatory so our single line text
fields labels here multi-line labels
here labels for our check boxes here and
we have two columns of check boxes so
they're split up into two
homes right now and then we had
basically we were trying to make these
controlled components so I had done it
on maybe one of the components one or
maybe a few of them yesterday just to
start out with and Patrick went in and
actually made it so that it applies to
all of the components but it happens
like without having to manually go to
each component and do it right so that's
what what this whole thing is doing is
just making sure that the value of each
component is determined by the state the
this the state in for that particular
element let me show you it's gonna be a
lot easier if I just show you this in
dev tools so you can see what the state
is so let me do this
some things are just hard to explain
without a visual okay so let me bring
this over so you can see the result of
what all that does so this is the state
now for that service request component
so you can see each field has its own
key in state and the value in state is
going to be the value that shows up in
the field so for instance I could go in
here and change the state for name so
just some nonsense here and it's
actually changed it here in the field I
could add something in for the phone
number and you could see it changed the
state here so what happens is on change
and if you watch yesterday you know like
I went over this yesterday but just to
reiterate for anybody who's new on
change it changes first the state and
then once a state change occurs that
triggers a rerender
then the value comes from the state so
that's the flow of how this works so why
would we want to do this it makes it
really easy for us to get all the values
to keep track of everything so this will
make more sense once we start sending
this data somewhere I'm sure that this
is not the only way to do it but I like
this way to do it this seems to be
common among people when I've seen them
do this this kind of thing like in
tutorials for react so so anyway I'm
just saying I'm not it's not like we're
inventing anything new here but it could
be a little bit more complex than you're
used to if you haven't done forms and
react before all right so that's that's
basically what's happened like I said a
lot of the other stuff was for the
testing so you'll see that like when we
go to commit some code you'll see the
test run
okay also I have the livestream going on
Instagram as well simultaneously so if
anybody's interested in seeing that it's
it's just the shot of me in my office
working so it won't really add that much
to the actual coding part of it but it's
there if you want it okay so let me
check the live chat and just say say hi
and see what's going on
okay cool it looks like thank you thank
you everyone in the lab shot it looks
like there are some some new people who
had some questions and you all took care
of that for me and gave some great
answers so I appreciate that
I definitely want to make sure that
newcomers to this stream always feel
very welcome and you all did a lot I'd
do a great job of that so thank you for
that and keep up the good work
okay great I'm looking through it looks
like you all took care of every question
well you uh you all are awesome yes John
so John Hanson said say the save state I
guess is much better than the old Ajax
stringify yes
exactly yeah that's what that's what I
was thinking of when I was saying like
if you haven't done this in react the
other way I was thinking of is well
you've probably used something with Ajax
and submitted like that okay Sebastian
see you later
Sebastian is frequently in the live chat
and helps out with a lot of pull
requests and things and he's working
security of Music Festival this week so
he can't be here so good luck with with
that and hopefully there's nothing
serious you have to deal with you just
enjoy the music
okay let's see Pablo
Pablo's here you commented on a video I
saw the comment but that was like kind
of right in the middle when all the
craziness was happening that I explained
earlier and why I started late
let me think oh you were asking about
the Udacity course okay so I want to
give you an answer that the Udacity
course is paid the the react nano degree
from Udacity is the course that I was
referring to it is a paid course it is a
little bit expensive they had a sale on
it but I think the sale is over
but if you're looking for free resources
right now I don't think you'd ask City
has any free react resources they have a
lot of other free things that are useful
but not react so if you want free react
stuff Codecademy has a has a class for
free that's browser-based and I think
learn code Academy has some YouTube
videos on it the beta curriculum for
free code camp I think users react more
I'm going to be honest I haven't checked
out the beta curriculum in a really
really long time so not sure what's in
there but um I think there's react stuff
in there so those would be my go-to
places right now if you're trying to
learn react and don't really want to
invest that much money which I totally
understand
if you weren't sure that you're actually
going to use it that much then it's
definitely not worth the investment
okay let's oh cool it looks like there
are some other suggestions coming up in
the live chat as well so thank you all
for contributing we're gonna have to
make I definitely need to make like some
sort of video and just bring together
all of your suggestions that because
there's been a lot of good suggestions
for react resources so I need we need
one place where I can just direct people
to because I think I frequently forget
good resources when I try to answer that
question during the the stream so I'll
have to record a good answer to that
so everybody gets quality answer and
it's not dependent upon my memory all
right so today all right I'm gonna leave
it up to you all what you want me to do
today because I have basically two
things what I was hoping to try to do
yesterday what we kind of started is
handle all this form data and actually
send it somewhere now I want to maybe
set up that somewhere and that would end
up being probably I would use Express
and nodejs
to take that data and do some stuff with
it that's gonna be kind of difficult
okay that's not an easy task at least
not for me because I don't often do it
so I have done it before but only once
before so we can try that or we can try
to do something that's a little bit more
beginner friendly and just build some of
the layout for the rest of the pages and
I will say for me today I've just been
feeling really like not not motivated
and come and tone it down I don't know
what's wrong with me today so if you all
want to put in the chat what you feel
like doing I'll do whatever you want but
me like my mind right now is saying do
the easy stuff today but I don't want to
trust my mind when I'm in this like
depressed state because I'm sure that we
can accomplish a lot of stuff even if we
do the hard stuff so I'll give everyone
a minute just to weigh in with their
opinions on what you'd like to see today
which they say either way is fine with
me
it might actually be useful if there's a
lot of beginners to maybe do some of the
easier stuff and it'll give me a I don't
know more time to research what I want
to do for the the handling of file
uploads and data actually let me
I've never done this before on air but I
feel like I just I really need to give
you a quality stream today so I know you
all can't see this right now you might
hear some of it so normally I get some
caffeine in before the stream but
because I had craziness going on right
before the stream I couldn't so I'm
gonna mix up my energy drink right now
it'll just take me just a minute and
then I'll have it normally I I do this
in advance so just just do a little bit
I don't need a lot I got a decent amount
of sleep but I ended up so yesterday I
told you I think I was gonna go to see a
doctor about my wrist so I ended up
spending most of yesterday evening with
the doctor well not really with the
doctor in the waiting room waiting for
the doctor and the good news is my wrist
is not broken which is what they
suspected that it might be broken but
it's not it's not broken but it is very
inflamed so I I have a brace so i'ma
show it on the stream so I have this
brace and if you if you're joining in
and Instagram you can see it and right
now the brace is off because I tried to
use the brace earlier and work with the
brace and it actually hurt worse so it
was really hard to try to move my hand
around I use like the the Magic Trackpad
thing for the iMac and it was it was
crazy and to try to type with it was
really weird I kept making mistakes so I
took it off so that's probably not the
best thing for it but I don't I don't
have time like I got to do I got a code
this stuff so I can't I can't I can't
mess around with trying to use that
brace so I'll put on the brace maybe
like later on it does help a lot when
I'm home
because I keep forgetting it's my right
hand and I'm right-handed I just keep
forgetting and doing stuff and then
hurting it worse so anyway just an
update in case you you wondered about it
which I think most people probably care
about the code and not necessarily about
what I'm doing but sometimes if I don't
give you a update somebody always asks
me about the update so so cool so I
think that's Phillip is that Phillip in
the Instagram so Phillip thinks that
that is a cool nerdy brace so yeah so
hopefully they gave you these these
pills that are supposed to bring the
inflammation down but it's probably
going to take a couple of days so
hopefully they work okay
so sorry for the delay but at this point
I think I should have enough responses
to determine what we should do today
all right so let me scroll up okay I
think this is the point where I asked in
the live chat and
[Music]
let's see okay so we gotta vote for easy
stuff okay
bobak asks why are you depressed I don't
know why I'm depressed and that's why I
don't think I should trust it so I have
like I have depression so I see a
counselor for it I take medicine for it
right so what I've found and I've had it
for I don't know overton maybe like 15
years or something so at this point I
realized that if I feel like I'm
depressed and I think about reasons why
I maybe should or shouldn't be depressed
and I can't think of any good reason why
I should be depressed then I should not
trust those feelings and I should try to
get over it however I can so today I
don't really think there's a really good
reason for me to be depressed there is
some stuff going on like some family
stuff that is is kind of I think will
base it I think my wife's grandmother is
probably going to die really soon so
that's like a little bit sad I don't
want to I don't want to downplay that
but I'm just saying like that's
something that is definitely legitimate
to be sad about but to be sad to the
point where like I don't want to do my
work I just don't think that that
connects like if anything I should be
doing more work to just take my mind off
it and because really like I don't I'd
rather be able to be there for my wife
and not have to have her worry about me
being depressed or anything so anyway
that's bottom line answer the question
is there's not really a great reason why
I should be this depressed today so
that's what I'm trying to get over it so
I've got my my G fuel energy drink and
I've got my live stream and I've got you
all which always pumps me up so I think
I'll be okay so don't worry about me
it's not like severe depression or
anything
okay so I think the only vote I got one
way or another for doing something was
do was easy stuff maybe I missed it but
that's fine with me we can do easy stuff
yeah so Brian voted for easy stuff okay
Dixie easy stuff
Conrad beginner stuff okay awesome let's
do that then
that's cool I kind of wanted to research
a little bit more and I had some
resources up on my other screen that I
still hadn't read all the way through
yet so it'll grow it'll end up being a
better stream when we do that then I'll
make less mistakes and blacks will
probably get it working and instead of
just making something that keeps
breaking okay cool thank you all for for
your input on that I appreciate that and
thanks for forgiving me a break today
and voting for the easy stuff
bobak SD you exercise regularly not not
like I should so I actually got back
into exercising so two of the last three
days I in the morning before coming to
work for about like a half hour 45
minutes I just did some cardio today
though this morning I didn't I woke up a
little bit late and I didn't exercise so
I'm guessing like that probably has
something to do with it I feel better
when I exercise and that's what actually
my counselor says I'm supposed to
exercise like pretty much every day for
45 minutes so that explains why I'm
probably feeling depressed cuz I haven't
I've just been so busy it's that's
something that's easy to cut out you
know there's other things that I have
like I have to take care of the kids I
have to come to work and the one thing
that I can just cut out and nobody's
gonna get upset about is exercise
alright cool so Bhavik I really
appreciate that
bobak says notices that that it
definitely helps with state of mind for
exercise so I appreciate you taking an
interest in me and giving me advice on
that okay let's get started so I really
I do appreciate you all caring about my
mental health but I'm sure there's some
people in here that came for some code
so let's get let's get to the code and
let's see what page we're gonna do so
we've done home logos we didn't do
anything yet for logos this is just the
demo card that Rohit had made the card
component so I don't think we're gonna
do logos today but we'll see if that's
the last thing left over we have posters
okay posters is fine letterhead is fine
sure story service question one tutorial
hmm
actually the tutorial is gonna be really
easy let's just start with that
let's get a quick win right off the bat
and set up the tutorial view so I'll
start as as we've been doing and I'll
show you what we currently have on the
site and basically what we're gonna try
to imitate and possibly improve upon if
we can so the goal we spoke about this a
few streams ago but the goal basically
is to to make this as close as possible
to what it is now just so that people
don't get freaked out by it and they
still know what to do but improve where
we can improve so the changes to the UI
are gonna be minor but hopefully
meaningful and in a good way for our
users all right so here's the tutorial
look look how simple this is all I had
was a card with a bit of text at the top
and yeah that is really my work phone
number so I don't care if you all see
that you can get it online anyway so
it's just a YouTube video of me clicking
around and explaining to people how to
use this so that's all we really need to
do we're just gonna put it in here now
the the one UI change that we have been
thinking about and testing on some pages
is to not use cards quite so much and I
think in this case we can definitely get
rid of this card because we have kind of
this double card effect going on here
because we have shadows right now on the
video and on the card so it just pops it
up another level there which I don't
really think is necessary
I think it'll end up looking like a card
anyway if we get rid of this one because
we have a shadow on the video and then
we can just put this text above it and
see how it looks so let's try that and
I'll have to I need to figure out what
the URL is so I'll inspect this pay
on my other screen just to grab the URL
so I don't really think there's that
much value and showing showing you all
one on my the screen that you can see me
just going through these elements
actually maybe I will and then you can
see you can see for yourselves whether
or not this was built properly you can
see the structure so this was my first
project for when I started working here
here we go okay so this is our our video
and I think I'm gonna grab I'm gonna
grab all of this so caught the elements
now will this copy
I'm hoping this copies everything inside
the element I'm not really sure if it
will let's let's test it up awesome it
did okay there's several options to copy
when you go to copy from dev tools and
I'm always like not sure what each one
does and I've never taken the time to
try them out okay so we have that I'm
gonna leave that there
so it's it's easy for me to get to and
let's go to tutorial here we go so we'll
go to the tutorial page and I want to
bring this over here I way too many
pages open at this point so I'm gonna
get rid of some of them
oh actually this reminds me before I get
rid of this one I had someone messaged
me on Twitter and say that they were
getting an error when they were trying
to run the program and the image they
sent me an image of the air and it was
side nav is on line 34 so if anybody
else is getting this error let me know
but basically the air was saying handle
clothes is not defined so that was the
area that it was giving for this page
and that's why it wouldn't run when they
tried to do NPM start so if anybody else
has this error please let me know I'll
try to figure it out I mean it's a
little hard to figure out since I can't
recreate the error on my machine so I
think it I don't think they said what
operating system okay I can see from the
screenshot there they're on a Mac as
well so yeah it's just it's really odd
that that's not working so if you have
any ideas please let me know and because
I mean I want I want you all to be able
to you know pull this code down and try
it out I actually had from the last
project I had quite a few people who
pulled down the code for that last
project we did with next Jas and
actually did projects based on that so
they took you know what I had modified
it to suit their needs and came up with
some really cool projects so that was I
was like pleasantly surprised that that
you all were doing that with I don't
know that I can really call it with my
code because we work collaboratively on
it so much but with our basically they
took what we did and just ran with it
and did you know did their own thing and
so that was really cool so I'm gonna get
rid of this side nap now I'm gonna say
don't save
okay so here's our tutorial page and
let's go to another page and just copy
now that I look at it I don't really
think there's much we need to copy from
here this page is gonna be pretty simple
okay yeah I'm not gonna worry about
copying anything and this page can
actually be a stateless functional
component so let's let's make it a
stateless functional component and then
that way if anyone's not familiar with
that or why or you would want to do it
or how to do it then this would be kind
of a good a good demonstration of it
so oops let me I forgot to start my
Pomodoro clock so let me do that now as
well
also I still someone sent me a Pomodoro
clock that they had written I think in
Java I still have not had a chance to
test that out yet I've not forgotten
about it though and I will test that out
so if you're watching just be patient
with me please okay so let's take let me
bring up
I just wanna see if this is in the react
dogs especially if there's someone
that's new definitely check out the
react dogs but we'll go through this
yesterday we had a situation where we
did something and they had a really good
explanation of it in the react dog so I
think it might be a good idea that
whenever we're doing something in react
to have those ready and then that way
like when you all have questions it'll
be right there you can see it I can
refer to that I'll be able to give you
better answers than I normally would be
able to so I'm gonna try to remember to
do this okay so okay so here's so you
can have a component as a function or
you can have a component as a class
right now we have it as a class but we
don't need it as a class why would you
want to component as a class well if it
needs to have state if you need to do
some some things with it like if you're
gonna have the like use the component
lifecycle methods then you probably want
it to be a class correct me if I'm wrong
- in the live chat but this was my
understanding of it but if you don't
need to do any of that stuff
then stateless functional component
probably the way to go
so let's take let me make sure I'm not
missing something important before I go
on ok cool so don't think I'm missing
anything important and let's see I don't
think we did any stateless functional
components yet in this project did we
now I don't think we have we definitely
did in our other projects though
let's see
I thought we did enough now that I'm
actually looking for it I can't find any
there we go finally I found one all
right so you can see like how much more
simple this is so side by side instead
of making a class and then having a
render function in return we've replaced
all that with just this all right so
we're making use of some arrow function
which that some es6 stuff so if you're
if you're not familiar with that check
out more on es6 but it's basically a
shorthand for a function and it has some
other very nice benefits in terms of
what the value of this ends up being but
that's basically it that's all we need
so you can see we have that and then we
just export at the bottom you know as
normal so let's do that
and I'm gonna check I'm gonna check the
live chat right after I do this just
because I want to make sure I didn't say
something wrong when I was explaining
that and I know you all will have
corrected me okay so here we go and
that's it that's all we need instead of
what we had before so I mean it may not
seem like a big deal but it definitely
making things look a little bit cleaner
and if you are making a lot of
components you know that little bit of
time would add up not only in creating
it but then also going back and having
to read through components you know
that's two less lines that you have to
scan through you know with your eyes so
I'm sure that that oh adds up at some
point okay so we want a container and
actually it might it might be useful to
grab our container classes from
somewhere else so just so you don't type
it over again so this is way more than
we actually need but we'll get rid of a
bunch of it and now I lost I was hearing
a tutorial so we need our container
class and a row and a column so let's
get rid of most of this and we'll just
keep that first part
there we go and we're gonna keep our row
you'll get rid of this column
and we've heard of this
okay now we can bring this over and we
need to change our class to class name
so in the last project we had guess
that's it
and our last project we had actually had
something that let us use class and it
just automatically worked that out for
us but I don't think I brought that over
to this project so I may end up bringing
it over but at this point I do need to
change the class name that's probably
better so that you all don't get
confused like if someone's joining in
and didn't realize that I had that going
in you know running then they might not
understand why I can use class and they
couldn't use closed let's see I'm not
sure if these props will work we'll say
we'll try it out I mean it'll be obvious
if they don't work so save that let's
check out what's happening alright cool
so what is this
so it definitely doesn't look like we
want it to look but at least we have it
on the page so we have a video and we
have some some sort of shadows going on
so let's see actually this would be a
good time to check materialize and see
if they have something for for video or
I'm sorry material you I think I said
materialize
I meant material you I actually you know
what that that might be the reason I
don't have I brought over the classes
for video container but I didn't bring
over any of the actual code so that
makes sense so I'm gonna bring that over
I I totally forgot I did say I was gonna
check the the live chat so let me check
okay sorry I forgot to start the end
Rock server let me do that
Who am I okay
sorry about that so if you would like to
check out the project you know as we're
developing it in real time you can go
here I'll paste this into the live chat
if you can't see the link in the live
chat if you can't get to it for some
reason I'll leave it up on the screen
for just a minute but as you can see you
know here's all our connections
now you can you can follow along you can
inspect things you're not limited to
seeing what's on my screen
my boss just sent me a slack message in
Latin I'm not familiar with one of the
words so I need to google translate this
who
so I'm pretty sure he just I'm gonna
leave out the name of the company's
product but he's I'm pretty sure he just
told me in Latin that this company's
product is destroyed so maybe something
that we use here at the universities as
crashed okay he was responding to
another message I'd sent him earlier
about the analytics code no not working
so anyway I used to teach Latin so if
you're confused as to why he's sending a
message in Latin that's that's why and
then he he also knows quite a bit of
Latin as well so don't normally just
speak Latin
okay
so I don't normally get distracted by
other people in my my office whenever
I'm working but occasionally it happens
and I like when it happens because
that's like accurate of a normal work
days sometimes you get interrupted with
things okay it seems as if there's some
good discussion going on in the live
chat so I'm just like looking in the
middle of it here so I'm gonna I'll
check back in on this a little bit later
and see if I can figure out what's going
on but right now I'm I'm not exactly
sure
okay
all right it doesn't look like I'm
missing anything that I need to address
in the live chat right now if you did
ask a question I am gonna come back
later on and try to find all the
questions and answer them so just stick
around if you can alright so that was
definitely the end Rock was definitely
on the screen long enough for everyone
to navigate there if they wanted to so
as I was saying there's right now
there's no Styles associated with the
classes that we had on on this video so
let's pull over the styles and let me
see
I think I had yeah these are just from
materialized okay so let's go we have
materialized here so let's pull it from
here because I'm sure these are all from
a much older version of materialized so
I'd rather get the newer versions I know
that they did change a bit about their
box shadows to make them a little bit
more you know accurate to the material
design spec so there's definitely been
some some updates since I built this so
I want to get the updates
alright so video container we want this
for sure and I'm gonna put this
okay we want to add this in our styles
I'm not sure how how small is too small
for a CSS well let me show you it's
gonna go in it this is pretty much gonna
be it I do maybe I need to bring this
depth over but if I'm gonna bring the
depth over I might want to bring more of
them I guess if I'm just bringing the
depth this one depth thing over it
should be fine
okay
I definitely don't I don't want all this
stuff see that one half no I don't want
that half so I don't want it apply to
all of this stuff because I don't want
to mess with any of the material UI
things so I'm gonna get rid of all of
this okay but yeah you can see so
they've definitely this is definitely a
different black shadow than the one I'm
seeing in the original version so they
definitely updated their box shadows
since then
normally I know I don't do the files
like this but I thought I tried the
command line is definitely faster
hmm my editor is okay good I thought my
editor was gonna crash you know right
there in the middle of right here in the
middle of the stream that would be bad
okay let's
let's link to materialise there we go
and then now we're gonna want to import
these styles so this is actually really
cool and in react if you do split your
Styles up like this and two separate
files you don't have to load them
everywhere so normally if you are making
a website you may have all your Styles
in one file in the act
they just load on every page whether or
not they're needed
so I mean you don't have to do it like
that but that's kind of what people
normally do or at least what they have
done in the past so with this we're
gonna import this into this component
and then whenever we use this component
which in this case this component is
actually going to be the entire tutorial
view so the Styles will get pulled in
when we need it and they won't need to
be used right if we don't need it so
that it just helps keep things smaller
so let's I just want to pull over
here yeah
no actually that's not what I want
because I want I don't have anything
else here we go
thank you I wanted to copy to save time
and just copy this this import but I
guess I guess it won't save me time
since I looked everywhere
already I'm assuming that we had
here we go
this is what I was trying to do so I
don't want it there when it's
okay so when we import this in we have
to we have to think about where we're at
in the the folder structure so right now
we're in the views folder so we need to
go up one folder and then down into the
Styles folder so that's why we have dot
dot slash so that takes us up then down
into Styles then into video dot CSS okay
so that's like the main reason why I
just wanted to copy it so I wouldn't
have to think about that and ended up
not really saving any time and I copied
it into the wrong file anyway not there
yeah just I'm just laughing at myself
now okay now that's in the right file
let's see if that had any impact on how
this looks
none not at all really
what is going on
it looks like why this video container
not being applied a lot video container
you know
okay so it seems like what's happening
let me show you what I'm seeing which is
a little bit weird so this video
container class it's not the styles
aren't being applied
this is really odd
okay so evidently that these have all
been brought in somewhere else and so
that was being applied so this was
probably brought in with the pool
request for the upload input yeah so
that's cool so if that was needed there
let's see what's going on with our oh
that's what's happening didn't change it
okay
all right well that's slightly better
right so we have it's not going outside
the bounds here but that's definitely
still not what we want okay so in about
two minutes I'm going to check back in
with the with the live chat so let's see
what's going on here I'm gonna bring
this over
how much I make it so that we can see
both things at once okay so we have this
border and it's quite
it's quite sick
there we go so I'm not sure what was
going on with the border but this is
better right I mean that's that's much
better we don't want the border there
okay so from I'm not sure where that
border was coming from let's see
okay I guess that was just the default
and for some reason there was nothing
you know what there there's probably
some stuff at the very beginning of the
materialize file that gets rid of a lot
of the default styles so I'm guessing
there's just default the iframe you know
default border they get rid of it at the
top so we didn't include that stuff so
that's why it was in there so I'm just
gonna put it since the video video
container iframe was it on the iframe
yeah yeah so that border was on the
iframe so since we are already have this
here and it's already targeting the
iframe let's just put border none' here
and then see well double check make sure
that works okay cool that's working all
right so I'm not sure if I went too fast
through that sorry about that but
basically if if you didn't know what I
was talking about there some default
style so when you see stuff like user
agent stylesheet elements get default
styles and usually if you use a
framework CSS framework one of the first
things that they do and their main CSS
file is just get rid of all the default
styles so they'll just sometimes they
just set it all like to none or to zero
or anything of something so that it
doesn't interfere with what they're
trying to do later on so that's what I
was talking about and so we don't have
that because we didn't import all of
materialized we just imported the pieces
we need so we could if we really wanted
to I guess import that part of
materialized if I run into more things
like this it might make sense but since
it was just this this the only thing
time I've seen this something like this
happened so far it was made more sense
just to put border none' you know right
on that that iframe since we're already
targeting that in our CSS file so
that's why I did it like that so
obviously we want to do a bit more with
this I definitely want to make sure it's
centered and that's gonna be an easy fix
we just need to fix our column classes
and then everything should be looking
pretty good we're definitely going to
want some sort of padding here maybe
even vertically align this so if we
haven't already done so we might want to
bring over the some of the vertical line
stuff from materialise not exactly sure
it'll work I have to see it it might
work without using like the whole page
structure I think as long as we have our
container row column structure it should
work so that's what I'll do after the
break is over
and the break will be to catch up on the
live chat also the Instagram feed is now
finished so thanks for watching if you
check that out and that will be
available for 24 hours if you want to
view it later the link for my instagrams
in the description and I just I just
grabbed my phone and like clicked it
with my my right hand which is the bad
hand because I just keep forgetting and
it it hurts let me let me scroll up a
bit I know I missed a lot in the live
chat because you all have been been
talking a lot which is awesome I love
when the live chats active so I'm gonna
scroll all the way up to the top because
I'm afraid I'm going to lose some of the
messages because there's so many of them
it looks like right now I'm not not
losing anything so I shouldn't lose any
ones things and also I'm gonna skip over
some of the questions got really good
answers already in the live chat from
you all so I'm gonna skip those so if if
you answered if you ask the question
early on and I don't get to it
then that's probably why if you really
want me personally to answer it let me
know either put the question again in
the live chat or send it to me on
Twitter
Issachar yes so I'm new to programming
is react a better version of jQuery I
don't they're not comparable in the same
way so I would say no but if you're
going to use react you can probably do
anything you'd want to do in jQuery you
could do it in react without having to
use jQuery so in a sense I guess you can
pretty much replace I don't it's not
like you can just bring react into a
project that you're using jQuery and and
replace it so yes I I wouldn't compare
them directly I guess but if you are
using react then you probably don't need
jQuery you could do everything with with
just react
the only thing I'm thinking of that just
like Ajax stuff but you probably want to
use fetch for that anyway so
because react doesn't have you know
their own way of handling things like
that
Ron - runner asked hey Jessie what do
you think about semantic UI I don't I
don't know really anything at all about
semantic UI I've seen it mentioned
before in the live chat but I haven't
had a chance to check it out so sorry
but I don't I don't really have any
opinion about it at all
Ron - runner also asked what's the best
UI for react I don't I don't really know
how to answer that question either
because this is the first project that
I'm actually using a UI framework
specifically for react I've attempted
before to use materialized with react
and to try to make it work the only
downside is so things aren't organized
already into components and it uses a
lot of jQuery so that's why I've
switched for this project to using
material UI but I haven't really tried
any other ones out so I don't think my
opinion is worth much at this point
so karyesh should I learn jQuery to
learn react or angular or can I start
with them right away you don't need to
learn jQuery to learn react or angular
and in fact if you really want to learn
react I say you can just get jquery and
go straight into react I don't know if
it's still like this with angular but at
one point angular had like a jQuery Lite
that came with it I guess where you
could do some stuff with jQuery and you
didn't have to bring in all of jQuery so
I don't know if they still do that with
the newer versions of angular so let's
see ok Doosan says and sorry if I'm
mispronouncing that but Doosan says
react and angular are not using jQuery
okay so evidently the newer versions of
reactive gotten rid of jQuery completely
so yeah so then I would say I don't know
enough about angular to say for sure but
I would say definitely if you really
want to learn react
you can skip jQuery
okay so my five minutes is up I'm just
gonna scroll a little bit just because I
as I said earlier I don't want to lose
some of the earlier messages
okay Doosan asked how long are you
programming I'm not sure if you mean how
long have I been programming or how long
this particular stream will go this
stream will probably go for like about
another hour and if you were asking how
long have been programming I need to
write this down I always have to think
let me think
like five years I guess but maybe not
like maybe like really seriously trying
to be a good JavaScript developer for
like I don't know like three or four out
of the five years okay so let me let me
get back to some of the code I want to
check so I'm stopping at the live chat
at the point where it was 2:22 p.m. for
my time so I'm gonna write that down so
I remember and don't have to try to find
where we were at
all right that's another thing that I'm
trying to write with my right hand and
that's not so easy right now
okay so let's change these column
classes and get this oriented properly
so right now the reason it's over here
is because we have it set to take up on
medium sized screens and bigger we have
it set to take up only half of the
screen only six of the twelve columns we
are we have imported the column classes
from materialized so we are using
material UI but we've also imported some
stuff from materialized so I I suppose
like that's probably confusing so that's
definitely worth repeating probably for
every stream I think I have I think I
put in the description but I didn't
really explain it in the description so
basically what we want to do is just get
rid of this and now let's see how it
looks all right cool much better much
bigger and at this point I do want to
try to have this align vertically now
we're gonna use flexbox for this so that
means it may not work in older browsers
which is fine with me especially this is
a site that's geared for an internal
audience and I'm of the opinion that I'd
rather try to push everyone here at the
university to use modern browsers
because that's the safer thing for them
to be doing so I don't feel bad about
not supporting older browsers if it was
an external site I might think more
about it depending on the audience but
internally like there's there's really
no excuse you know no one even needs to
update themselves in fact they can't
update anything themselves the computers
are all on lockdown all they need to do
would be call or email the IT department
and they would update the browser so
given that given that all it takes is a
short phone call or email I'm definitely
fine with only supporting the latest
browsers for internal sites which ends
up being cool because we could do you
know cool things and not worry about
supporting older stuff so
let's grab I'm not gonna do the flexbox
vertical line from scratch because
materialise already has some of that
built in so let's find it and
materialize and pull that in let me see
I had to think for a second of what it
was called so we have this feline rapper
and why is it not
alright well let's pull this in and then
we'll also need it a v-line class which
I'm not sure why that is in a different
spot so let's bring it I'm gonna put it
in here for now just to make sure it
works but I think this would probably be
better if I put this in our main CSS
file because we're probably going to use
this on every page so it'll be better
there
actually that's weird I really thought
there was supposed to be a v-line class
and not just a wrapper what is going on
maybe things got updated and a newer
version of materialized and so I'm just
I'm not familiar with that let me check
the documentation then see what I'm
missing
yep Wow okay so in the newest version of
materialize they got rid of the needs so
before the way it worked is you had to
have a v-line wrapper on the container
div and then inside I would have to
actually put the class V line on this if
I wanted it to be vertically aligned so
I guess they've changed that and that
that must have been pretty recently
either that or I've just been adding
that class for no reason for a long time
and didn't realize that I didn't need it
okay cool so that means we have
everything we need right here and you
can see basically you know here's what's
here's what we're doing okay now there
are some vendor prefixes so they're
already there we don't have to worry
about doing that which is good which is
one of the benefits of just copying this
over instead of trying to do it
ourselves especially because we're not
using any type of preprocessor ideally I
would have it set up so that I could use
sass and then also set up so that it
would put all the vendor prefixes on
afterwards but I don't have that set up
for this project when I'm not using
create react app or web pack I do know
how to set this up with gulp I have no
idea how to set it up without using that
so maybe one day I'll figure it out but
not today so let's throw now I just need
to figure out what we're what I want to
put this on
so I need it to be alright see our
container actually is not gonna be a
good thing to put it on because you can
see the container is already completely
filled up so what we what I want to put
it on is hmm I may need to change change
this a bit
okay
all right so I've added a min height of
100 VH so this is viewport height so
that means it'll always be as tall as
the viewport we'll see how this looks if
I wanted to really get like a better
vertical line I would also maybe do like
a calc and then do a 100 the H minus the
top of this so cuz like right now you
can see like it actually goes down even
below so for now this will just give us
a better idea if if our V line will work
but it won't be exactly vertically
aligned in the middle the reason I did
min height instead of just height is
that if I set height to 100 then what
could potentially happen is that you
know for a screen was like this let's
say we were on a phone and landscape
mode then it might cut things off so we
didn't we don't want that so we want it
to be at least 100 of the viewport
height you know or more okay so let's
add this on for a container we'll give
it the vo line V line wrapper and then
we'll also give it a style of
okay
see what happens that's not good all
right let's see what's going on okay we
have our container it's the right height
okay we have display Flex good now let's
see what's happening okay so our row
this row column and definitely not
working all right let's try something
different then so let's take the wrapper
off of this one and let's save it
all right so here's what we're gonna do
we're gonna put it
let's put our height arm in height on
our column and add the rapper also to
our column let's see if that works
no again not working okay let's see
what's going on
okay display flex but I mean that's
that's what's messing things up is the
display flex so let's see what's going
on here
all right I'm gonna look at the live
chat in just a second to see if you all
can know what's going on here well it's
not bad I mean we probably could have
expected some issues if we're trying to
mix and match CSS from two different
frameworks okay so it looks like right
now it's our height yeah we're having
issues with our heights
actually on the iframe on this
you should
hmm okay let me check
all right yeah it looks like add a lot a
lot of advice here so let me read
through it
okay John Hanson said I figured out how
to set up and webpack three with sass
and CSS loader okay
instead of figured so but it's giving
errors can't resolve past a separate
module SATs folder okay
so John you'll have to let me know if
you do get that working I'm very
interested in that okay Patrick said the
autoprefixer is on by default and create
react app apps so I can delete the
vendor prefixes I don't have to worry
about it
cool let's do that now so I don't forget
I like that it does it makes everything
look a lot more messy to have all these
vendor prefixes in
okay let me let me look
always thinking about on my other screen
I want to look at our original page
since we have it working there and see
what the difference is in the CSS I'll
actually no we don't we didn't vertical
align that so I can't look to that let's
look at materialized
and see what's going on
yeah
shouldn't see what's difference
so here's our container
okay both display:block oh it's not a
high problem
is that all is that all we needed
I got really too much and I just take it
okay
all right there we go okay so the
problem was just I I had wrongly assumed
that it was a height issue but it was
actually a whiff issue so I had looked
and saw a zero for what I just assumed
was the the width because I don't know
about you but almost every time
something like that happens it's usually
the height that gets set to zero I don't
know that I've ever had a a width set to
zero when I actually had a height so
anyway this works now we just have to
make sure we set the width to of the
video container to a hundred percent it
was a hundred percent
oh no that's the iframe so the actual
container needs to be with 100 percent
oops okay so this is with a hundred
percent and that was it I think that's
all that was though that we needed to
change okay
now as you can see that doesn't look
like it's vertically aligned okay the
reason being right we have we have this
container div that is 100% height but
it's getting pushed down by the height
of of this so let's figure out how tall
this is this is kind of where I wish I
had sass because I could put some
variables to make it a little bit more
automatic so that if this height changed
I could have it automatically change
here but we'll just have to remember to
change this if we need to see
that's terrible how was my height that
let me see that's what I want
I really wanted to be I wanted it to be
like an a round nice round number but
it's close enough to 64 that I think if
we do let's see
Minh heights is 100 VH how do we do this
calc
if I set it inside of here I never tried
it let's try it okay so if you're not
familiar with calc and CSS it's let you
do calculations so I want min height to
be 100% of the viewport height minus 64
pixels which is the about the height of
our Arnab or top enough so let's see if
that works
cool okay so this is actually closer to
being really vertically aligned does
that look right to use at vertically
aligned
wonder why I have that little bit down
here oh let's check it out yeah that
looks about right for being vertically
aligned cool okay what do y'all think
does it look good to have this
vertically aligned would it have been
better to have it a little bit closer to
the top I'm okay with this
actually we never put in the the text so
let's bring this text over as well
whoa
oh because I'm using flex all right that
makes sense
alright don't like that that messes up
our vertical alignment
so let's think what we could do about it
hmm we could put
but this text make more sense being
below the video this almost seems like
what I would rather have happen is for
someone to watch the video and then if
they still can't understand what to do
then they can contact me I actually I
can't even remember the last time
somebody contacted me about this so no
one seems to have problems at least they
don't call me about them some maybe it
would be better to put this below anyway
let's see we all think and my Pomodoro
timer stop right now so now's a good
time to get your opinion on this and
check the live chat again okay cool it
seems like we're in agreement then it
would make more sense below okay cool
so sometimes it just it just takes like
I mean I hate to have like really long
periods of silence in a video but I just
had to sit back and look at it for a
minute I'm just kind of think about it
so sometimes that's at least for me
sometimes it's really helpful to just
stop and just stare at it for a while or
even think sometimes I just close my
eyes and just think about what it what
it would look like if I move things
around and that that actually really
helps me at times I can work out a lot
of issues in terms of layout and design
you know just visualizing it and not
have to spend a lot of time trying to
change the code to make it look like
that and I'm not really any good with
like sketch or Photoshop or you know any
of the stuff people use so that that's
why if you haven't noticed already like
I pretty much do my design in CSS like
right there because I'm I'm faster with
CSS than I am with sketch or a similar
program
okay so I've scrolled up a bit back to
where I left off at oh man John Hanson
said I hope your wrist heals fast it can
take up to a year depending on how badly
you wrenched the tissue
well I'm thank you for for that
I'm really glad it or I'm really I
really hope that it doesn't take a year
because it's like like I use my wrist
for work constantly right it's not like
I'm have any weight on it but I'm just
moving it a lot and then lately at home
so my my youngest is nine months old and
she wants me to hold her constantly so
if if I'm home she gets so mad if I'm
not holding her so it makes it hard I'm
either holding her with my right hand
which hurts or I have her in my left my
left arm and then I have to do stuff
with my right hand so I really hope it
heals fast
okay I'm gonna so I'm going through
trying to find the questions right now
through the lot Chad do son says you
should do something like talk with Jesse
sometimes so cool would that would that
be more basically like an entire show
that's like a question and answer
session then I've thought about doing
that before I'll have to ask on my own
channel I can do whatever I want so I
may I may do that and then I'll have to
see I'll have to ask Quincy if he'd be
alright with doing that on free code
camp because I don't want to do anything
on my own for free code camp like change
up the format without asking him because
he you know he invited me to do this I
don't really want to take advantage of
that but maybe it would be cool the only
thing about doing things on my own
channel is I always get less people
because they're just a way less people
subscribe to my channel so the alert
goes out to a lot less people like my
own channel has a few hundred I might be
up to like five hundred now I'm not
really sure and free code camp is up
over like a hundred eighty thousand
subscribers but that is gone maybe I'll
do that at some point
you know mob and I just saw your my
Franciscan thing
John Hanson says I was curious why the
absolute top positioning on the top for
input fields are different than the rest
let me go to that quickly basically
these are single line text inputs and
these are multi-line so this is just set
a bit higher to indicate that it's
multi-line
okay I'm gonna scroll down my time is up
but I'm gonna scroll down a little bit
more actually let me check the time Wow
it's okay I'm just gonna go right to
stick with the live chat and get to the
questions because there's still a lot
that I haven't gone through yet and
we're coming up we've already been going
for about an hour and 40 minutes so I'd
like to keep it to hours or under if
possible so basically we've gotten this
page I kind of felt we get farther than
this page but we had some some issues
that like obviously this wasn't showing
up and I didn't get right away
why so basically what I'll probably end
up doing is moving this underneath and
then sorting out the vertical alignment
so that it looks okay I think I like how
it looks better if I can find a way to
include the height of this and this into
the vertical alignment so that this
wound up being pushed a bit higher which
I think I would like anyway but it'll
look fine because we'll have this at the
bottom so like the hole will be
vertically aligned even though this will
appear to be slightly to the top
I think that'll look nice also I want to
make these are links so I want to add a
link color so you can see right now
right now they have this link color I'm
not really sure if I want to keep this
color because it can be hard to read so
I might maybe make this color just a bit
darker or go with a completely different
color I do have some other colors I
could work with that are in the color
palette so I'll see but other than that
this page is pretty pretty much finished
so this this may be our first completely
finished page with all the proper
content and everything so the other
pages we have we have the elements on
the page we just never put in the right
content okay so that's it for that let
me let me commit this right now the
that way if you're not familiar with did
you see how to commit also you'll see
what's going on
now when we do our our testing on commit
so check it out so we've added an
entirely new CSS file here and then
we've edited our tutorial dodges so I'm
gonna do get add and then just do dot
because that will add everything you
could name the specific file but it's
faster if you know you want to add the
file even if it's just one it's faster
to put the dot now if we do a status we
can see these are both ready to go ready
to be committed so let's to get commits
let's go
as you can see we got an error component
is defined but never used oops okay we
didn't need component right so if you if
you look here we made this a stateless
functional component so we unlike our
other pages so like let's look at home
Jase right we were saying class home
extends components so we needed to bring
in component we don't need to do that
anymore so we can actually get rid of
this we do need to keep react I believe
so now we could just do this and that
was you know we got the error which is
great that we get the errors now rather
than you know getting the errors later
on after afterwards we try to commit and
so that's much much better so let's
check our status we see we've we've
modified so I do want to do a get and
and and also I didn't need to put the a
in there so sorry about that we've
already added so I can just do the M for
the message if I were to left the a and
that means we're adding and committing
at the same time which would have been
good since we we needed to add this
anyway but I don't want to confuse you
you don't really need the a if you're
just adding a message okay so this first
part is Auto formatting and looks like
that that worked and now it's running
the tests there we go cool so you can
see we have test setup right now for a
four of the components and it passed all
of them it tells us how long it took you
know all the all the tests that passed
so really cool
now I'm gonna push that up to github and
now everything that we've done is
available for you to check out in the
repo on github in the master branch okay
now to the live chat so if you're just
sticking around for the coding that part
of the stream is finished thanks so much
for watching totally understand if if
you need to move on and do something
else if you'd like to stick around for
the question and an answer that's
awesome too if you have a question
please put it in the live chat now if
you can't stick around or if you'd
rather ask something privately you can
direct message me on Twitter or really
on any other social media I've have
people message me on Facebook LinkedIn I
think where else I've had messages on
Instagram so pretty much wherever social
media you can find me on you can message
me on there I've even had people email
me I'm pretty flexible with that so I'm
just gonna go right through the live
chat I'm about half way through all the
chat messages right now I'm going to
keep going down through I'm gonna try to
get most of the questions let me go for
just a second I saw the head of my
department just peeked in my door so I
just want to make sure it's not any
emergency thing be right back
okay I'm back oh I'll be just a minute
okay I'll be right back
okay I am back I'm really sorry for that
that that was probably the longest gap
that I've ever had in my stream so
apologies for that especially if you're
if you're watching this later on
I guess you cannot fast-forward through
it or skip ahead so so I it was I guess
it wasn't exactly an emergency but it
was about the project that I'm on right
now sort of so the live version of this
is obviously live and people are
submitting things through it frequently
we get submissions every day but our our
project manager so we have someone who
looks at all the submissions and then
assigns them to people and she is in
Iceland right now on vacation which is
awesome but I now have to sort through
all these submissions and assign them if
they're if they need to be worked on
immediately otherwise I can wait they
can wait until the person who normally
does them gets back so anyway it was
about a recent submission so I need to
make sure that I double-check that so
I'm gonna write a note for myself right
now so that I remember to check that so
let me get back to the live chat now I
hope I didn't lose too many people it
looks like we're a little bit below
normal but I'll still get I'm gonna go a
little bit past the time I wanted to so
the stream is gonna be a bit long in the
tooth hours so I can get to the
questions since I left you all hanging
current for so long today has been like
definitely an above average amount of
[Music]
interruptions
okay scrolling through
okay it looks like there was a nice
discussion here in the live chat about
what's used for back end so it seems
like everything was covered so I'm
seeing node PHP Python C sharp Ruby so
really cool great great discussion in
there okay dawn xavier as how did you
manage to get the z-index working with
material UI cards I've tried CSS but
material UI keeps on resetting the
Styles try to make it with styles and
same luck okay let's let's see let me
check
what's going on with our with our cards
so we do have we have cards here on the
home page
[Music]
I guess the I mean the z-index just
worked I don't I didn't do anything with
it
so I don't really know I'm not sure I'm
not exactly sure since I don't know what
the what the issue is
so don't save you if you have a link
like to a repo or even like a live demo
I can check that out and try to give you
a better answer but I have not had any
z-index issues with the material UI
cards
okay now dotnet is isn't part of the
discussion
Bava casks anyone know why he's using n
grukk instead of node I am I'm still
using node in the background and rock is
just so that you all can can view the
site so like my node thing is running on
localhost and then you all can check out
the and rock link okay it looks like
that was that was already explained
thanks
who's that Kevin thanks Kevin for
explaining that in a lot of chat
okay it looks like I could see you all
caught the fact that I had included
component up here and I didn't really
need it so thanks for catching me I
didn't see it in the live chat at the
time but thanks for catching that and
explaining that that shouldn't really
have been in there it was just left over
from copy and pasting
hahaha Kevin said I guess in the
pre-commit lint step it will be caught
if he doesn't notice that is exactly
what happened Kevin you're a smart man
Don Xavier there there's a discussion
then left chat about small like size of
CSS files and things like that
don't Savior says simulate 3G and you'll
see that smaller CSS is better yeah so
actually I I recommend that sometimes I
I do all my development with 3G so I
wouldn't say all it when I get to the
point where I'm trying to speed things
up on a site like I'm doing speed
optimizations I try to just have it set
on a 3G network all the time to really
get a feeling for what's what users on a
3G network will will experience also I
just saw a video about this the latest
version of Chrome I think from 60 will
let you simulate not only a 3G network
but also phones that don't really have a
lot of processing power so I'm not
really sure maybe it's just on canary
right now I didn't check to to use it
yet so if you Canaries like the latest
version of Chrome
I don't have canary open right now but
that's also that also will be useful you
know because not only does the network
connection matter but the processing
power as well
kevin says and loading time optimization
you need to take into account caching
yeah that's true
yeah so Kevin explains more if it's a
big CSS file but it doesn't need to be
downloaded again because it's cached and
then you navigate around the site you
actually might increase the performance
instead of having a lot of small CSS
files that need to be downloaded in our
cat so yeah actually that's that is a
really good point it might be
interesting to I don't know if love time
with this project or not but it would be
really cool when we get it to a more
finished state to compare the load times
doing it either way so like we could
have a branch where we combined
everything into one file and a branch
where we have it all split up and then
compare that might be really cool to do
I hope I don't forget that idea because
later on like before we before we launch
it that would be the best time I think
to test it out and then we would decide
you know which one we should launch Jan
thanks Jan notice that I was trying to
import the wrong CSS file a little while
backs huh thanks you all always catch my
mistakes before I do I should just as
soon as something doesn't work I should
just look at the live chat immediately I
would save a lot of time like that
let's see John Hanson at says does
everyone use autoprefixer from post CSS
or is that not needed nowadays I have
used it on projects recently I guess it
depends on what you're working on so I
think next and then create react ad will
auto prefix for you but if you're not
using one of those then you would want
to use an autoprefixer so also it
depends on what browsers you're
targeting as well but really I think I
mean if you're once you add it it
doesn't really take any extra work and
you might get you know compatibility
with some extra browsers for it so I
think it's definitely worth it
oh okay Joseph thank you
justices don't forget to fix your props
for the iframe frame border and allow
full screen so let me let me do that
right now
that's definitely something that I would
probably forget unless I do it right now
so I mean there should be I should be
getting an error message for it so let
me show you the error first okay so
we're getting these errors for frame
border law full screen so I think I
mentioned this when I first pasted this
over and I basically just said well I'm
not sure if these will work we'll find
out
so I usually forget whether or not these
work so basically to make these work we
just have to camelcase them whoops
now that should get rid of the errors
yeah all right cool iframe elements must
have a unique title property that's
interesting okay so our iframe needs to
have a unique title I've never heard
that so
cool alright alright these error
messages always just show up locally so
cool
I Joseph again thanks for for letting me
know about that
okay a little while ago I was mentioning
using sass with webpack and in regard to
that John Hanson mentions setting up the
sass loader with webpack is
straightforward and works it's the post
CSS autoprefixer that's messing up
webpack so okay good to know
Oh embarrasses Chrome has issues with
Flex so
I have to see because I just remember I
was trying to use flex to position
things on an admin dashboard and my home
project and read about some issues with
Chrome and flex it looked good in IE an
edge but not on Chrome I think there was
something about using inline flex
instead okay off to keep that in mind at
least for right now on Chrome you know
this is doing it was really what we
wanted it to do so maybe there's some
other stuff with flex box that just
doesn't work properly
brian says why is he only wishing he was
using SAS and not actually using it yeah
that's a great question
I just never I didn't set it up so we
just just kind of started working on
this project and it didn't set it up so
that's the only reason if I because I'm
not really sure how to set it up so if
if I have time and I guess I could set
it up I just didn't think it would be
that big of a deal but at some point I
guess it would be good for me to figure
out how to get it working with create
react app in this case and use it
okay Patrick says like so we have a
scrollbar showing right and we don't
really need a scrollbar showing on this
page so definitely want to figure out so
we had like a little bit of extra space
down here that was below the container
so I'll have to get rid of that figure
out why it's there get rid of that
because for right now the scrollbar
doesn't look bad but he rightly reminds
me that on Linux and Windows the
scrollbar will show and not look that
great so that's yeah that's definitely
important to get that sorted out so
thanks thanks for bringing that up
Patrick okay Patrick says I'll set up
SAS and make a pull request tonight if
you want just let me know actually
Patrick if if you would like to do that
and you have time to do that that would
be really awesome and helpful so
definitely don't expect you to do it so
don't feel don't feel at all obligated
but I would be I would appreciate it a
lot if you did do that otherwise if you
don't have time but you know you could
send me a resource and then I could try
to research it a bit and do it as well
that would be cool too
brian says is it complex to set up with
react meaning SAS I'm not a developer
but I thought he was using gulp which is
obviously pretty easy to set up with SAS
with yes so I'm not using gold for this
project but for previous projects I had
SAS set up with gulp for this project
it's webpack but since it's create react
app all the webpack stuff is kind of
hidden away yes I'm not really sure how
it would work in this case
oh cool Patrick says there are actually
instructions in the readme for create
react app to set up SAS so I feel like a
noob now yeah I was actually looking
through some of the create react app
stuff today I wasn't looking up for SAS
I was looking up for how to do setup
like a server JS file and handle some
things with our form inputs so there is
so much stuff in the documentation for
create react app so from now on I'm
gonna go there first what I'm trying to
do something because there are a lot of
different use cases that are addressed
there it's a really really good resource
webb says hi Jesse I started your series
yesterday and I'm on day four now and
loving it awesome thanks for saying that
I'm glad glad you're you're loving the
series so far and that's cool that
you're able to join in live today
oh cool John Hanson says I can put the
text inside the same div container as
the Flex child that's yeah that's kind
of what I was thinking is I'd have to
put it to avoid having them appear side
by side I'd have to put them all in one
container so let me let me do that right
now
let's do that now see how it how it
looks
is that right yeah I did it right okay
cool
I need to I need to delete this
okay cool much better
is it just me or does it look like
there's way too much space on this side
now I can figure it out later
oh yeah
there we go that new div I made needed
have a width of 100% cool alright so
thanks John
that was definitely the way to go okay
publishers are you creating a new branch
and then merging it back in the master
one nice it'd be nice to see how it's
done
actually I didn't for this one I'll try
some more for tomorrow stream I'll try
to remember to do that and if I don't
remember in your if you're able to join
live Pablo remind me and then I'll
definitely definitely do it I have done
it in previous videos I don't think for
this project though but I don't want you
have to go back and search through its
it's like a lot of hours of video
content so I'll definitely do my best to
remember to do it tomorrow
me Jess si hey how's it going glad you
can join us but John B says take some
notes you know so you don't forget
yeah that's your I should just write it
down
as I'm writing you down right now okay
actually now that I think about it if
you do look back at some previous videos
I think it's actually in the video title
that I'm like merging or something so if
you want to see me merge something I'll
still try to do tomorrow I think I did
put it in the title of the video so you
could just scroll through the playlist
the live coding with Jessie playlist and
see see the title or pro even search for
it I can't remember exactly I'm pretty
sure it had the word merge in it
okay jonbi I just just clarified about
the taking notes that this was in
reference to cashing a large CSS file
over a bunch of small okay so let me it
would be good to put that in in here so
[Music]
I'll say for Pomodoro cycles just to
combine all the files because the actual
testing should be pretty obvious right
off the bat okay so now it's in there so
it won't forget okay so John Hanson says
webpack has a common chunk plug-in that
will build a common bundle file that
will make two requests per page view the
common files hold shared code is cached
and then dedicated files with specific
code okay that's interesting
so that may be like kind of best of both
worlds scenario perhaps we may end up
with three branches that will test Mike
says hey hey just started this series
last night I'm excited to catch up on
the videos on your next five-minute
break could you just do a quick 10
second click through on a couple of
pages of this project yeah sure I'll do
it also so let me do I want to do two
things for you here one is I'm gonna
paste that link to and rock so if you
can open this link you can click through
the site live right now if you want to
and then just in case you can't go to
that link I'll just click through a few
pages
homepage just some cards logos this just
as a demo card right now but it'll be
very different later on just some cards
these are cards these actually would
normally have it never works on
localhost for me but these would be
images and then the card title below
we got a share story form our service
request form and then the tutorial which
we we worked on today which did I not
say that yeah I didn't I just didn't dev
tools I'll have to save the with 100% on
that container div that we added
patrick said so you are just going to
email the request form I thought this
was connecting to third party back end
yeah it is so what I currently have it
doing is an email goes out with the data
the data gets saved in a Google sheet
and then it also gets sent to our
project management system we're using
rike and they have an API so I can send
the data and files it's a little bit odd
so I can't send everything all at once
what I have to do is create a new
project and I can send a it with that
like all the text input data and the
checkbox data then I get in return
it gives me the ID of that project and
then I can take the ID and then send the
files but I need that ID first so I
actually have to make two trips to get
everything over there but anyway yeah
that's what's gonna happen so I will you
hopefully I'll be able to continue doing
all those things although I'm open to
setting up some sort of lightweight
database and just not using the Google
sheet so replacing the Google sheet with
some sort of database but that would be
a big learning experience for me because
I've never set that up before
oh cool Mike said that that link the N
growling did work awesome okay yeah I'll
leave the end grukk server running until
I leave today so it'll be running for a
little while after the video and then
that way if anybody wants to keep
messing around with it then it'll be
there
cool Patrick said I'm looking forward to
seeing you hook all that up yeah I'm
looking forward to doing it as well
hopefully I can make it all work
I mean I made it all work with using
jQuery and before so hopefully I can
make it work again of course that was
all client-side now I want to do a
server-side all right I've gotten to the
end of the the live chat so today was
really long stream but that was at least
partly due to me being interrupted which
is cool it happens we did we got some
stuff done you got a lot of questions
answered so a pretty good stream and
I'll be back I think my schedule is free
in the afternoon tomorrow so I should be
able to stream at the same time 2:00
p.m. Eastern to my normal time and we'll
see maybe maybe we'll start working on
some of that server-side stuff to handle
the form data tomorrow but thanks so
much for all your help there's really as
always
you all make whatever I'm working on you
know so much better than it would
otherwise be with just me working on it
thank you for for the pool requests so
Patrick and Kevin had pool requests over
the last 24 hours
thanks so much for that and yeah I'll
see you all tomorrow have a great day